[Music]
this food might taste delicious
and these items might look necessary but
you will probably change your mind when
you see the true story behind what you
use every day
some of them are disgusting and others
could be dangerous for your life just
wait until you hear how you are putting
something
toxic into your body every month if this
is your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you 10 everyday
items you'll never buy again
knowing how they're made mcnuggets
you've probably already seen this
disgusting picture of pink slime people
believe that this was how they made food
at mcdonald's but you'll be happy to
hear that this story is false
and to prove it the fast food restaurant
decided to show the world how their
mcnuggets were actually made it is still
disgusting and we're eating animal
corpses after all
but this is still better than what we
imagined the process starts by deboning
whole chickens and then set aside the
breast meat for the mcnuggets so don't
believe the rumor that it's made of
chicken legs it is not true either the
fat is trimmed off the breasts and the
meat is collected into a bin
then it goes straight into the blender
and it's mixed with seasoning and
chicken skin for flavoring the chicken
meat is then turned into different
shapes you've probably never understood
what they are but mcnuggets are actually
shaped like balls bells
boots and bow ties after this it's time
to send them into the fryer the meat is
still a little bit raw
so the final step will be to send it to
a mcdonald's restaurant where it can
finally be cooked
after hearing the rumors it is actually
not that bad unless you're a vegetarian
but just wait until you see what's
coming next
gummies if you think that vegetarians
will be happy to hear how gummy sweets
are made you are wrong these candies are
made of gelatin
which is made from boiling the skin
bones and cartilage of a pig the first
step is to sanitize the pigs and roast
them before having their skin peeled off
meat industry will do their job and the
gummy industry will get the leftovers
then the discarded skin and bones are
magically turned into some sort of white
strings
colorings are added to make it more
appealing and what is left of the pig
then goes into a machine that turns it
into beautiful candies that we love to
eat the process was recorded by a
belgian filmmaker named alina neepkins
who then showed it to the world
everything started with a woman eating a
candy and by the end
everyone was disgusted to see what she
actually put in her mouth it was only
one short film out of a series of videos
documenting the way our favorite food is
made and as you can imagine
it doesn't get better so next time that
you're eating gummy sweets
remember that a pig doesn't have the
chance to live a beautiful life because
of this
we suggest you tell your vegan friends
that they're doing something wrong if
you see them eating gummy bears
toothpaste
we put this in our mouths every day and
we don't even know what it is
at this time you shouldn't be scared of
how the toothpaste is made but of what
is in it
egyptians started cleaning their teeth
since thousands of years and ancient
greeks and romans did the same thing at
that time
toothpaste was made of different
ingredients but it usually had one
important side effect
it made people's gums bleed it didn't
get better over the years because in the
20th century
some german scientists developed
radioactive toothpaste but don't worry
it did get better shortly after a
dentist noticed that locals in a city
had fewer cavities than most people when
he understood that it was associated
with a high natural level of fluoride in
their water
this ingredient was quickly added to the
toothpaste that we know nowadays
what we put in our mouths twice a day is
actually made of fluoride
baking soda chalk flavoring and a lot of
things that we cannot understand by
looking at the ingredients on the box
but is it actually safe on their website
colgate says that if your child eats a
large amount of toothpaste you should
call the emergency hotline listed on the
toothpaste tube or contact a poison
control center immediately so is it
really a good thing to put this in our
mouths every day there's probably a
better alternative
red bull red bull gives you wings but
this is also the reason why you will
fall from too high once you realize that
it is not as good as you think anyway
they don't have the right to say this
anymore since someone sued the
caffeinated drinks giant for falsely
claiming that their product could make
them fly but let's get back to the
ingredients
when people read the ingredients rumors
started spreading that taurine was
coming from a bull's balls
don't worry it's not true according to
the website taurine is an amino acid
naturally occurring in the human body
and present in the daily diet conclusion
this is probably safe we know that
drinking sugar isn't so good but we'll
survive however what you should be
worrying about is the high level of
caffeine in this product and the impact
that it will have on you in the
following hours
it takes only 10 minutes for the
caffeine to enter your bloodstream and
for your heart rate and blood pressure
to rise
you might feel like you have more energy
after 15 minutes but an hour later you
will experience a sugar crash and feel
more tired than you were before
then it will take 12 hours for caffeine
to be removed from your bloodstream so
is it really worth it
we don't think so sunscreen you might
have heard people saying that sunscreen
was dangerous but what is that really
about
sunscreen is made to protect your skin
by absorbing or reflecting
uva and uvb rays espf reveals the amount
of sunburn protection that it can
provide when you use it correctly
however it must take something really
special to protect us from rays that can
be life-threatening so there could be
something really dangerous in the
sunscreen too
some scientists think that the
nanoparticles and the chemicals could be
small enough to slip past our skin
and into our bloodstream and cause
inflammation which could be linked to
cancer
others say that it could cause damage to
a person's hormone system this is why a
lot of people started to worry however
it has only been tested on animals and
not all scientists agree so yes
sunscreen can be a tiny little bit
dangerous but going outside without
protection is just worse
one in three cancers diagnosed worldwide
is a skin cancer
and most of it is caused by excessive
skin damage so maybe using sunscreen
isn't so bad
after all if you really want to be safe
stay inside or cover yourself from head
to toe
this is the only way that you will
protect yourself from these dangers
as long as you don't overheat hot dogs
if you're wondering what was that pink
slime associated with mcdonald's we
might have found the answer
hot dogs look tasty once they're cooked
but seeing how they're made will make
you want to never eat this again
are you ready before they're turned into
beautiful sausages hot dogs just look
like a disgusting gooey meat it all
starts with three different types of
meat
pork beef and chicken pieces of meat
leftovers are used and it already
doesn't look good they are quickly
turned into strings
and then they are transformed into a
weird substance that we wouldn't like to
touch
food starch is added followed by salt
and other flavorings people in different
regions have different tastes so the
ingredients can vary
water is then sprayed into the mix and
everything is blended together
corn syrup adds a little sweetness and
water makes the hot dogs juicier and
this is when we see the goo
pouring out of a tube everything is then
turned into the sausage that we can
easily recognize but we don't care
anymore because it is already too
disgusting for us
so let's summarize this story something
pretty gross is turned into something
even more gross until they give it a
different shape to make it look tastier
we will never look at hot dogs the same
way ever again
jelly beans after seeing what they do to
gummy sweets we hope that we'll still
have the guts to eat jelly beans too
making these candies actually looks
pretty sweet liquid sugar is mixed with
starch and glucose before being poured
into bean-shaped molds they sit for a
day and then go into giant spinning
machines along with more sugar
hot syrup and artificial flavors before
being packaged and sold
in total it takes 7 to 21 days to make a
jelly bean there's absolutely nothing
wrong there and we think that it looks
great but have you ever wondered how
they make these disgusting flavors like
vomit boogers or rotten egg once they
decide the exact flavor they want to
mimic scientists go to their labs
this is where they use a gas
chromatograph and a mass spectrometer to
heat up the fluid and vaporize the
juice's molecule one by one
it seems complicated but this is how
they break down the molecule to better
analyze the smell and recreate it but do
you know what this means when they
wanted the jelly beans to taste like
stinky socks
they had to do this according to a jelly
belly spokesperson a flavor scientist
aged his own socks and sealed a plastic
bag for a couple of weeks before putting
it in the gas chromatograph
we think that we'll stick to the normal
flavors like strawberry next time
so we wash our body with this every day
so we think that it should be clean but
you'll be surprised to learn what soap
is actually made of it was invented by
the ancient babylonians around 2800 bc
at that time soap was made of wood ash
water and animal fat so yes
they were using what was left of the
body of an animal on their own body but
did it change
not really soap is still made by
combining fats and oils with an alkali
even though oils are plant-based
fats still come from animal sources so
once again you should warn your vegan
friend and advise them to use something
else
but there is also something that
everyone will probably care about if you
use antibacterial soap it could have
more negative consequences than benefits
that's because it contains triclosan a
chemical that's a known endocrine
disruptor and a skin irritant it can
have an impact on the thyroid and
reproductive hormones it became such a
problem that the us fda decided to ban
19 active ingredients in antibacterial
soaps including triclosan if this is not
enough to convince you
we don't know what will and anyway there
is no evidence to prove that
antibacterial soaps are better than
simply using soap and water so you
should stick to animal fat instead
tampons when you put something inside
your body for a week every month you
really hope that they're safe this is
why you won't be happy to hear what
tampons are really made of we know that
they are made of cotton
rayon and synthetic fibers but there are
a lot of other ingredients that
manufacturers are hiding from us simply
because they are not required to tell us
everything and when you learn about the
toxic shock syndrome and the terrible
consequences that it can have you know
that there might be something wrong down
there the toxic shock syndrome was
mostly caused by synthetic
materials but they are no longer used in
tampons sold in the united states but
why are some women still sick
people also found out that rayon is a
byproduct of dioxin which could cause
cancer even though the fda replied that
it was not enough to be harmful people
think that putting many tampons
inside your body for a week every month
and every year could be dangerous
and it just gets worse when there is a
fragrance which is associated with
allergies respiratory distress
and effects on the reproductive system
don't think that pads are better women
also found low quantities of chemicals
in these products
which are associated with cancer and
neurological problems so until we know
what is really in there
using a menstrual cup could be a better
idea m ms
let's end this with something a little
sweet shall we sometimes there is just
so much sugar everywhere that just
seeing it can't be good for our diet but
we can't resist the temptation so let's
take a look at how m
ms are made anyone who enters the
factory must be super clean they also
have to wear a mars branded lab coat
gloves hard hats
safety glasses earplugs and hair nets
and this woman was just coming to visit
the first part of the process is to mix
all the ingredients for the chocolate
together then it is tempered to the
temperature needed to create the right
shape the little chocolates are sent
through cooling tunnels and then they
add colorings which takes a long time to
create those vibrant colors
however no one is allowed to see how
they place the letter m on the candies
so it's still a secret and this is how
it takes 10 to 12 hours to make one bag
of m
ms we know that there was way too much
sugar everywhere but this time we think
that we won't be able to resist the
temptation we'll eat them anyway were
you surprised by any of these everyday
items don't be shy to tell us what you
think in the comment section down below
we love to hear from you
and that's it for 10 everyday items
you'll never buy again
knowing how they're made if you want to
see more stories like this make sure you
watch
10 gummy foods that taste better than
real food thanks for watching